[Music]
welcome back to this Hannity special
justice in America the collusion
obsessed House Judiciary Committee voted
this week to hold AG bill Barr and
contempt for declining to hand over the
completely unredacted Muller report
despite the fact that top Dems now have
access to all but two full and seven
partial lines of the Muller report but
they're redacted in accordance with
federal law not a single Democrat not
one has bothered to read it and talk
about hypocrisy let's not forget how
Democrats reacted when Obama Attorney
General Eric Holder was held in contempt
over his handling of the Fast and
Furious scandal watch this to bring this
contempt of Congress against the
Attorney General the Republicans are
contemptible the rush that they are
putting on it is just inexplicable what
are they doing what are they doing
having people want jobs they're going on
witch hunts the Republican majority
intends to bring a contempt resolution
to the floor against the Attorney
General to say that this is a terrible
use of Congress's power and time is an
understatement this is not about the
facts this is about politics they have
not found any evidence that this
Attorney General was hiding anything
that he had lied to anybody they still
do not have any facts to support this
ill legitimate investigation to our
Republican colleagues shame on you Wow
joining us now with reaction American
Conservative Union Chairman match lap
Judicial Watch President Tom Fenton and
Fox News contributor Tammy Bruce is
joining us in studio here in New York I
want to thank all three of you to be
here you know the fast and furious
things a little close to my heart I was
there in Congress would have first
started Matt and I gotta tell you they
were knowingly and willingly the
government gave two thousand weapons to
the drug cartels and we have a dead
Border Patrol agent and yet these same
people I mean compare and contrast the
reaction to that versus what's going on
today
yeah people get killed in these terrible
circumstances like fast and furious the
AG was compelled to turn over records
which he stonewalled Congress over for
the first time in over 200 years the
house has moved to condemn the Attorney
General for not willing to be
scrutinized by a staffer on the
committee which you know is an absurd
criteria we haven't done for two
centuries without some kind of
negotiations he's willing to testify by
the way on the Mullah report he doesn't
have to turn over to Congress it's at
his discretion he chose to turn it over
to them to make it public he chose to
make an almost unredacted copy available
to the leadership of of the Dems and the
Republicans in Congress and the
Democrats don't even want to read it
because you know why they know there's
no collusion or obstruction in this
report it's just politics and they want
to continue to play politics no this is
the thing it's heavy it's there in black
and white it's right there in front of
them all of the report except what's
required by law I liken it to the
Supreme Court you know when they come
out with a ruling they don't know the
press conference in S could answer
questions from other it's just they're
from to review how in the world do the
Democrats have any credibility on this
well they don't they're they're
effectively attacking the Attorney
General for following the law right now
I think that's perfect for the Democrats
because they hate that they hate that
law but this is really when you've
really ginned up your base on something
as ridiculous and hyper absurd like
saying that the president of united
states is or is a Russian stooge or a
Russian spy what how can you top that
and you've got to top it and the only
one thing you can say I guess now the
line is that there's a constitutional
crisis but the American people you know
they're smart they're this is also an
indication of the contempt with which
the Democrats and certainly Nadler in
particular hold of the American people
in that you wouldn't be saying this if
you had any respect for how the American
people are viewing this and what's at
stake and how you would be viewed you
think everybody is just a dumb rube and
they're not going to be figuring this
out they can I think actually you would
know like walk across a couple hallways
to see this they don't need to jump
through hoops to see it and the American
people want them to do a job I don't
think they had this in mind when they
voted him into power in the midterms no
I look I think the Attorney General is
doing an absolute fantastic job
no nonsense been there done that he's
doing exactly what he wants at what he's
supposed to do Tom Judicial Watch is
just I mean they have led the charge to
trying to expose what our government is
doing and compare and contrast for us
your experience with the Obama
administration because it's not as if
they were open transparent and complying
with the law along the way were they no
and the Justice Department especially in
the Obama administration led by Eric
Holder for a good period of time was a
black hole in terms of transparency
unfortunately as you know Jason it
continued under Jeff Sessions and the
Justice Department still so you know I
recognize you have these fights between
the legislative branch and the executive
branch about documents but this is a
trifle of a fight this material was
essentially being made available within
a few the last few weeks and they
immediately rush a contempt resolution
against the Attorney General to me it's
an abuse of power and it fits in
perfectly with what happened during 2016
when the Democrats abused power through
the FBI and DOJ to target president
Trump they continued through the Moller
operation and that smear of a report and
now the cudgel has been picked up by the
Democrats who don't want to talk about
the criminal conspiracy their party was
involved in in 2016 and 17 to target
president Trump with illegal spying
they'd rather talk about this pretend
fight and with the Attorney General
smear with Attorney General bar who they
are smearing and you know this this
awesome power they have to hold someone
in contempt you know it's pretty darn
serious when they start invoking it
lightly because they're effectively
saying Attorney General the United
States need to be put in jail over a few
lines of text that we're fighting about
it shows you where the Democratic
mentality is here that they just want to
jail their political opponents the rule
of law it doesn't matter
and Matt it did Tom's point there are
they just trying to diss
tract from the fact that we have a
pending Inspector General report and
that the Attorney General is looking
into spying and other types of things
that the Democrats may have been doing
previously yeah if you actually think
about it you know because the Democrats
played stall ball and had this 22-month
$35,000,000 investigation on this
ridiculous and ill-founded charge of
collusion now we're back into the
election season think about it Jason
they raised it so long that now it's
about their wrongdoing and that's what
we're gonna be talking about when this G
report comes out you know it all points
back to you know what I want to know
what did Joe Biden know that's what
Republicans need to start asking no it's
a good question we only have 30 seconds
left but but Tammy and Tom where do you
think contempt goes next real quick
I think obviously they're they've got
the votes to be able to do it I will see
if any Democrats have any courage to sit
to admit that this is ridiculous and
there are some in some vulnerable
districts so maybe not every Democrat
will go for it it's a distraction it's
going to go nowhere I think politically
nor legally thank you all for joining us
we really do appreciate